hay situaciones donde tienes algún tipo
de función como esta la cual es una
función no lineal fx igual a 1 entre x
menos 1 y está su gráfica o al menos una
parte de ella y justo lo que queremos va
a ser aproximar la con una función
lineal especialmente alrededor de un
cierto valor entonces lo que queremos
encontrar es una aproximación y déjame
escribirlo quiero encontrar una
aproximación lineal de esta función
efe alrededor de un cierto valor en este
caso va a ser alrededor de x igual a
menos uno entonces a qué nos referimos
con esto bien pues vamos a observar esta
gráfica de aquí y se observa cuando x
vale menos 1 f1 toma el valor bueno es
cercano como a menos un medio estaríamos
como por aquí y lo que queremos hacer es
aproximar lo con una línea alrededor de
y lo que básicamente vamos a hacer es
aproximar lo con la ecuación de la recta
tangente así que si tomo este color la
recta tangente se vería más o menos así
más o menos así y como puedes ver cuando
vamos más allá de este valor más allá de
x igual a menos 1 la aproximación se
vuelve peor y peor y peor pero si
permanecemos alrededor de x igual a
menos 1 la aproximación es bastante
decente es tan buena como puedas llegar
a una aproximación lineal o al menos en
este ejemplo es una aproximación lineal
muy buena así que cuando la gente diga
hey encuentra la aproximación lineal de
f
alrededor de x igual a menos 1 o digan
cuál de las siguientes es la mejor
aproximación y todas tus opciones sean
líneas entonces básicamente te están
encontrar la ecuación de la recta
tangente en x igual a menos 1 así que
hagamos eso así que para encontrar la
ecuación de la recta tangente primero
pensemos en la ecuación de una recta la
ecuación de la recta la podemos ver como
james es igual a m x + b donde m es la
pendiente y b es la intersección con el
eje
o bueno también hay otras formas en la
que podríamos pensar una recta podremos
pensarlo en términos de punto pendiente
donde podremos decir que quien menos
alguna que exista en esta recta esto va
a ser igual a la pendiente a la
pendiente que multiplica a x menos su
correspondiente x 1 es decir el punto x
11 se sitúa en algún lugar de esta recta
de hecho a veces me gusta escribir esta
forma de punto pendiente de la siguiente
manera como yo menos de 1 esto a su vez
dividido entre x menos x 1 esto es igual
a la pendiente y me gusta porque esto
viene directamente de la idea de que si
x 1 y 1 están en la recta entonces la
pendiente entre cualquier otro punto de
la recta y este punto va a ser igual a
la pendiente
de tu recta así que podemos pensarlo de
cualquiera de estas tres maneras
entonces primero vamos a encontrar la
pendiente de la recta tangente y ahí es
donde la derivada es útil entonces
primero ponemos aquí a efe de x fx es
igual a am y en lugar de poner esto voy
a escribirlo como x menos 1 esto elevado
a la potencia menos 1 y esto lo va a ser
mucho más claro para que podamos usar la
regla de la potencia y un poco de la
regla de la cadena cuando encontremos la
derivada porque ahora sí puede decir que
la derivada de f con respecto a x va a
ser igual a bueno primero utilicemos la
regla de la potencia porque nos vamos a
tomar la derivada de x menos 1 alan
menos 1 con respecto a x menos 1 bien
eso solamente va a ser bajar la potencia
que tenemos aquí
va a ir aquí y me quedaría menos 1 que
multiplica a x menos 1 esto elevado a la
potencia menos 2 y ahora habrá que
multiplicar esto por la derivada de x 1
con respecto a x pero bueno eso va a ser
1 la derivada de x con respecto a x es 1
y la derivada de menos 1 con respecto a
x es cero así que a esto lo
multiplicamos por 1 o simplemente si
queremos podemos quitar esto porque no
va a afectar nuestro valor y ahora sí sí
queremos evaluar esto cuando x es igual
a menos 1 entonces voy a obtener lo
siguiente la derivada de esta función
cuando x vale menos uno va a ser lo
mismo que bueno aquí tengo menos uno y
abajo me va a quedar como y en lugar de
x voy a poner menos 1 me va a quedar
menos uno menos uno
esto elevado al cuadrado pero menos 1 -
1 - 2
entonces me va a quedar menos
los elevado al cuadrado y bueno esto lo
puedo simplificar a menos 1
cuarto de lujo así que la pendiente de
nuestra recta tangente en x igual a
menos 1 es de menos un cuarto entonces
puedo escribir que la pendiente de esta
recta tangente es de menos un cuarto ok
y ahora que tengo la pendiente ya puedo
escribir por acá abajo la ecuación de la
recta tangente porque ya conocemos una x
1 y una reunión que se sitúan en la
recta de hecho queremos usar el punto
cuando x es igual a menos 1 entonces el
punto de aquí el punto cuando x vale
menos 1
efe de menos uno es bueno lo podemos
sacar de clint 1 entre menos uno menos
uno es menos un médium entonces es el
punto menos uno coma menos un medio este
punto se sitúa en nuestra recta es el
punto que estamos buscando ya que en
este punto la recta tangente la curva se
intersectan
y aún así podemos usar cualquiera de
estas para obtener la ecuación de
nuestra recta y entonces voy a decir que
james
- y uno que es menos un medio
- un medio esto va a ser igual
am bueno la pendiente que sabemos que es
menos 1
cuarto que va a multiplicar
bueno x menos x 10 x 1 vale menos 1
entonces me quedarían x menos menos uno
ok y si ahora usamos un color neutral
esto me va a quedar como déjame bajar un
poco la pantalla esto me va a quedar
como bueno ya que voy a obtener bien
más un medio ok esto va a ser igual a am
y ahora voy a distribuir este menos un
cuarto por equis y bueno observa que
aquí me quedan más 1 entonces esto es lo
mismo que menos
cuarto que multiplicada x menos 14
muy bien y si quiero despejar de que
ayer voy a obtener que james es igual a
menos un cuarto de equis y ahora voy a
restar un medio de ambos lados entonces
me quedan menos un cuarto menos un medio
bueno es lo mismo que menos tres cuartos
así que aquí lo tienen esta va a ser una
muy buena aproximación lineal tan buena
como puedas obtener una aproximación
lineal para esta función no lineal esta
que tenemos acá arriba alrededor de x
igual a menos 1 y observa que realmente
es muy cercano a lo que dibuje porque va
a estar cortando al eje james cerca del
valor de menos tres cuartos y bueno
podrías decir por qué no me pidieron
encontrar la ecuación de la recta
tangente en x igual a menos 1 y claro
que se puede pero en esta ocasión hay un
pequeño extra aquí de procesamiento
cognitivo ya que podemos decir muy bien
puedo usar la ecuación de la recta
tangente para aproximar esta función
alrededor de x igual a menos 1